vouloir légiférer là dessus et qu'il y
ait un tel niveau de crispation par
rapport à une question comme celle là à
mon avis ça renvoie à quelque chose qui
est tout à fait extérieur à la
linguistique ou même au caractère
historique de la langue etc
mais un propos politique et donc si on
veut interdire l'écriture un inclusive à
mon avis et des raisons politiques et si
on la défend par ailleurs
à mon avis c'est aussi pour des
questions politiques ça c'est un point
sur lequel je serais tout à fait
d'accord de revenir en tout cas le fait
de vouloir supprimer par le papa par la
loi me semble d'une immense stupidité
depuis en tout cas la position depuis
laquelle je peux observer sa lé problème
essentiel réside cependant dans la
visibilité van tu helmand deux à la fois
par les humains parlée par les machines
aussi les logiciels ne sont pas
forcément capable de distinguer les
formes créées par l'écriture inclusive
des problèmes de rédaction si les règles
ne sont pas forcément clair d'autres la
tension entre écrit et oral et cetera et
cetera font que peut-être dans les dents
les écrits officiels
eh bien peut-être à légiférer mais
disons il faut adopter une conduite
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient cohérents
on peut se demander si visage de
l'écriture inclusive ne renforce pas
certaine forme d'élitisme par exemple et
qu'il ya certains milieux intellectuels
militants qui qui peuvent plus
facilement se lève se l'approprier que
là on ferait on ferait preuve d'une
certaine forme de classicisme en
omettant en occultant le fait que c'est
que ça renvoie effectivement à des
difficultés qui a des difficultés
d'apprentissage etc
mais est-ce que à travers ces questions
là ce qu'on remet en question en fait le
principe même d'inclusivité dans la
langue ou bien est-ce qu'on remet en
question des desous problème de cette
question là c'est d'après pète d'accord
sur l'écriture inclusive et puis après
j'ai travaillé sur le fait de
l'homogénéité de la rendre plus
accessible et de travailler sur ces
questions là qui sont en fait des
questions beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
pratique dès l'instant où il ya une
volonté si une volonté en fait on peut
très bien travailler sous la langue de
cette façon là à mon avis il est comme
je le disais tout à l'heure à c'est
assez étonnant que que des députés
veulent légiférer sur ces choses là je
suis assez d'accord avec ce que ce que
nos intérêts a dit généralement en
linguistique on considère que l'usagé
juge de paix et d'ailleurs il faut
savoir que l'écriture et inclusive est
loin de faire l'unanimité parmi les les
scripteurs les enquêtes récentes qui qui
ont été réalisés je pense aux années
2017 2018 ont tendance à montrer que les
scripteurs humaines ne sont pas ne sont
pas convaincus de leur pertinence
alors ça vise essentiellement les
doublés abrégé et les néologismes comme
tous
li health qui sont une sorte de fusion
de terminaison de mots je ferais
remarquer que dans la dans la tribune
que nous avons consigné à marianne il y
avait cette tribune est écrit et dessiné
par des femmes aussi
et je voudrais signaler que dans ces
enquêtes d'opinion les sondés qui était
aussi pour une partie des femmes est
bien avec tendance à rejeter
certes dans une dans une proportion
moindre
l'écriture en cuisine mais elle le
faisait aussi de manière assez claire
est-ce que là on n'avait pas l'occasion
de faire intervenir et faire intervenir
des femmes faire venir à intervenir
aussi des dix militantes et militants
d'associations qui travaillent sur ces
questions il ya un mais surtout quel
ouvrage le plus emblématique sur la
question du langage inclusif et celui
des lianes viennot est ce qui n'aurait
pas été intéressant d'avoir des fans
dans un débat consulting moi je pense
que que ça aurait été intéressant mais
aussi de faire intervenir des pourquoi
pas des personnes france qui pourraient
aussi s'opposer à l'écriture inclusive
mais peut-être pour d'autres raisons
mais notamment pour le fait que c'est
une réaffirmation d'une certaine façon
de la bière